but first the latest on our top story
this hour deadly violence at a Costco in
California one person is dead and three
others are injured including the gunman
following an argument in the store the
gunfire sent shoppers racing for the
exits and ducking for cover the store is
in the city of Corona that's about 50
miles east of Los Angeles
Nicole Comstock of our Los Angeles
station KCBS TV has more terrible news
to report out of Coronas police
confirmed that one man was killed inside
of this Costco and two other people were
injured after they say the suspect got
into some sort of argument with another
customer inside of the store pulled out
a gun and then opened fire now there
were a lot of people inside of the store
shopping at the time who say they heard
at least seven to eight gunshots and
then crouched down inside the store
trying to protect their family members
well once they finally made it back
outside they realized their cars were
blocked in behind crime scene tapes so
really the only place they want to be
right now is home and they can't get
there soon enough well police are now
saying that there was an off-duty
officer inside of this Costco when the
shooting happened
but they're not saying what role if any
he played in subduing the suspects a lot
of people inside of the store want to
know now how this fight escalated into
the shooting reporting in Corona I'm
Nicole Comstock Michelle we'll send it
back to you alright Nicole thank you so
much